he went to welcome to co clanks when the
skull okay so what is the action is
gonna be accelerated dragon here yes
something that I tried recently and I
don't know hit it really i'm just
experimenting age for long castles those
moves look Rudy dangerous no he's more
conservative playin teenis does not want
to cast a long ok yeah that question how
to do this maybe this allows in five
okay let's make me five more difficult
for him to play and she just puts the
night their home okay probably have to
do this isn't this this position type
quite okay for me I know the e-file and
the e porn but white Bishop doesn't look
all that fantastic course you can argue
that my night never came in ok
particularly great either they will seem
not sure about this position at all so
we'll cover this unfortunately I cannot
play Queen to b6 which I would
absolutely like to play it really would
be nice to do
[Music]
what about Europe to be seven and then
queen to d6 it will probably probably
move the king anyway okay i put the
night here it's probably not so bad also
for prophylactic reason so that he
cannot regroup the bishop easily to see
to ok with before in i'm at least making
sure that i'm always always keeping the
the night down but how do i how do i
continue from this position maybe just
cover stuff i still would like the Queen
trade because that would allow me to
cover the e7 pause with my king so can I
do that for night if for I don't know if
that's really great again
h5 looks wrong that really looks wrong
and I don't know if I want to play Queen
to be six
yeah I don't know yeah don't really
threaten night don't really threaten or
anything here even night a force for a
real threat yeah night a for if I do
that I mean you can keep the Queen's on
I can also take on the six night XP sure
to be five but that's disturbing release
ok so if he takes it i can take with the
book i think if you take on your seven I
was more concerned if he moves the Queen
away if he takes on these seven here I'm
not quite sure about all that the thing
is keen to something so how to do that a
little bit worried about potentially h6
forever if I flame well I can take this
right h6 king of age right that doesn't
do much I thought that would be good ok
so i take him
now bring the King around this Luke c6
business that is going to be annoying I
don't know checking of the group's is
666 no that doesn't look so good
you
check check okay so i'ma pull knob but
this is the h7 porn is a week it really
is a week it's that way here 65 and I
never get down no problem I cannot do
much in that's probably a draw g5 king
at five and maybe I can do something
there and she can take all the pots it's
probably still avail now I cannot take
because of the because of the 49 morning
tricky guy mr. swang the skull check
check
very likely draw yeah so it is the draw
again run or not too great given the
rating difference but I felt like I was
in some some slight danger at least
maybe more I don't know your captioning
showed is a conservative option but
certainly possible yeah and now I'm kind
of unsure I don't really have all that
much experience the engine wants to do
it for ya this position type felt felt
really uncomfortable somehow there's
always this play against my against my
seventh on and the engine just wants to
do that I should have caught calculate
this a little bit it's just essentially
a double attack also eating this is a
failed pin now that would have been
better i guess here i'm struggling i was
also here i was really thinking you
might not trade but i can in the trade
is certainly not bad yeah hip should be
three found more critical to me and then
he i don't know my position looks it
looks very loose with all the week pawns
and the night is kind of stranded only
tool and i have wider spectrum and I
hear the ending I think I'm rather black
button maybe and I wasn't anything
serious check okay
to keep this having us better I could
have actually taken I completely yet
overlooked this possibility and then I
should have taken problem again ok here
is just the draw Kenny and the hair
should figure oh yeah it is it all but
even like before I think there were
little chance this is a chance to do
something ok guys thanks for watching I
have forgot to switch one then and the
decision was never anything else then 0
or 0.3 or something ok this thanks for
watching